California is known for its chill vibes
and beach towns but it's also home to
some of the best fixes for adrenaline
junkies everywhere here are ten
experiences your heart will only barely
be able to handle want to body surf
waves as high as two-story houses go to
the wedge this section of Newport Beach
has unpredictable and fierce waves up to
30 feet high that are shaped like you
guessed it wedges 30 feet waves not high
enough for you then you should enter the
Titans of Mavericks surfing contest at
half moon bay south of San Francisco 24
surfers every year ride thundering waves
up to 60 feet tall that crashed to the
ground in mini earthquakes want to test
out your fear of heights in Yosemite the
3,000 foot granite monolith known as El
Capitan draws rock climbers and base
jumpers who laugh in the face of fear if
you have time for a 12 hour round trip
climb up the 5,000 feet high half dome
above the Yosemite Valley a favorite
BASE jumper shortcut is hurling yourself
off the peak get your bungee jumping
kicks at the totally not ominous
sounding bridge to nowhere an abandoned
bridge in the San Gabriel Mountains it's
a five-mile hike and a 120 foot drop you
can even do this in the pitch-black
night if you like it spooky if jumping
isn't your thing you should hang glide
off the 350 foot cliffs at Torrey Pines
glider port in La Jolla soar over the
coastline on a tandem glide or solo
after flight school while singing I
believe I can fly for a more futuristic
flying experience go for a jetpack ride
at Newport Beach you zoom a whole 30
feet into the air in the middle of the
sea want more barrel rolls in your
aviation try the Top Gun experience at
Gillespie field in San Diego with no
experience necessary you can fly a
two-seater plane through an aerobatic
routine of spins loops and rolls if your
tastes tend toward the vintage opted for
classic thrill ride at sky thrills in
fullerton where you can fly in a 1930
style open-cockpit biplane and for the
last earthbound thrill rev your engine
at exotics racing in Los Angeles there
you can hop inside a Ferrari
ragini are Aston Martin and blaze around
the racetrack without having to worry
about pesky traffic lights or speed
limits that concludes the death-defying
adventure tour of california once you've
slept off the exhaustion you may need a
calming trip to wine country